Yeah, what did you do last session to
fix the zoom? People were very thankful
to you. Did you
Oh, great. Thank you. That's why I
noticed sound came on like 10 minutes in
to it. So, thank you.
I finally was able to get the They make
a second recording, so I replaced the
first one with the second one. Thank
you.
Okay,
while we're waiting to get started,
reminder, if you need one, that your
case is due before class on Wednesday.
The reason it's before class is we will
be talking about the case for the first
half of the next class. You know, where
we'll go through the questions and not
give you the right answer class case
because clearly there are variations you
can adopt that'll get you to an answer,
but talk about the big questions that
hopefully you dealt with in the case as
you went through. So, before 10:30 group
submission
PDF file would I would I would
appreciate because it's easier for me to
put the comments right into the file.
If you get it done early, don't wait
till Wednesday, right? Get it in by
tomorrow evening to get it out of the
way so you can move on to the rest of
your life. You know,
and I will you know, on the on the cover
page, as I said, summarize the numbers.
Your NPV finite life NPV longer life
cost of capital because I will pull
those numbers together for the class so
you can see the variations
across the class.
So, today we're going to actually
almost mop up investment analysis. Let's
see where we are. We've looked at how to
decide on a project, right? But almost
every project we've looked at so far has
been a stand-alone project. What does
that mean? You either take the project
or you don't.
So, when you have stand-alone projects,
you do exactly what we did. Estimate the
cash flows, incremental cash flows,
and if you're doing
present value, you take the present
value of those cash flows at a discount
rate that reflects the risk of the
project. Hopefully, I've I've repeated
that enough that it's become imprinted.
It's not the risk of the company, but
the risk of the project.
You get a present value, you can do an
NPV, you can do an IRR. If the NPV is
greater than zero, you accept the
project. If the IRR is greater than your
hurdle rate, you accept the project.
But today I want to talk about the fact
that sometimes projects are not
stand-alone decisions. What does that
mean? By taking a project, you might
have to reject another project.
Okay. So, these are called mutually
exclusive investments.
Take a very simple example.
My wife My My daughter is redoing her
kitchen.
And you have to pick a countertop,
right? You can pick an expensive marble
countertop that lasts 20 years, a less
expensive countertop that might last 10
years. Those are mutually exclusive. If
you pick one, you can't pick the other.
We're going to talk about how do you
pick between mutually exclusive
investments?
So,
in the real world, that's going to
become an issue either because you can
pick only one or because you have
limited capital, and we'll talk about
what limited capital does for you.
So, let's start with mutually exclusive
investments, and as I said, those
mutually exclusive investments can
emerge from the type of project you're
looking at, which is you can have either
only one countertop at a time, one
flooring at a time, one roof at a time,
you got to pick the best one, or because
you have limited capital and you can't
pick every project that comes along that
has a positive net present value.
I want to keep the two in play, but we
might deal with those separately because
the latter comes from limited capital,
and limited capital is fixable, right?
It's fixable if somebody gives you the
capital. So, it might be a question you
got to come up with a different kind of
answer.
So, when you look at projects that are
mutually exclusive,
here are the three ways you can go. You
can take the approaches we already have.
You can compute the return on capital
for each project and pick the one with a
higher return on capital, with all its
limitations.
You can do the NPV of both projects and
pick the one with a higher NPV.
And you can also compute the IRR of each
project and pick the project with a
higher IRR.
Many private equity investors, when they
pick investments, base it entirely on
IRR. We'll talk about why they might go
with IRR as opposed to NPV.
But we want to talk about why these
three approaches can give you different
rankings or different choices. So, when
you're picking between project A and B,
why might NPV lead you to pick project A
and IRR lead you to pick project B or
vice versa? Because that's going to come
into play if you're picking projects or
ranking them based on these approaches.
So, I'm going to take you through an
exercise where I'm going to give you
some very simple projects, and along the
way,
we're going to talk about what it is
that might lead NPV and IRR to different
choices. So, let's say you're a company.
You have to pick between two projects.
Very different cash flow
characteristics. On project A, you have
an upfront investment of a billion
dollars. You make 800 million in year
one,
a billion in year two, 1.3 billion in
year three. And then you have a big
negative cash flow in year four. You're
saying, "What kind of project would have
a big" Let's say it's a licensing
project where you got to pay some
upfront and some at the end.
The second project is a more
conventional project. You have a big
initial investment, which is negative,
and then your cash flows turn positive.
I'm just going to compute the NPV and
IRR for both these projects, and let's
see what comes out. Let's start with
the with with the IRR. What I've done
here is actually computed the internal
rate of return for this project or the
NPV for this project at different
discount for the two projects at
different discount rates. So, on project
B, you can see the conventional
drop-off. As my discount rate goes up,
my net present value decreases, and the
IRR is around 11%, 11.5%.
On project A, you have a strange
phenomenon occurring. Initially, as you
increase your discount rate, your net
present value actually goes up.
Why? Because remember you have that big
negative cash flow at the end? It's
coming in and hitting.
There's a point though where it peaks
and it starts going in the other
direction.
Already you can see the practical
problem you're going to run into here,
right? If you use IRR,
project B has one IRR, but project A
has more than one internal rate of
return.
I want to take the think back to those
projects and think about what it is
about project A
that gave you two internal rates of
return.
I know, okay, you want to try it? What
What is it about project A that's giving
it two internal rates of return?
Go back and look at the cash flows
because I think it might give you
idea.
I'm I'm sorry, what?
It's got to do something with the cash
flows, right? So, what happens in year
year one? Your cash flow goes from
negative to positive. Then what happens
in year four?
It goes from positive to negative. We
don't think about it this way, but IRRs
are roots to mathematical equations.
Thank God we don't actually solve them
as mathematical equation.
Every time there's a sign change, there
will be another internal rate of return.
So, if you have a project with five sign
changes, you could potentially have five
different internal rates of return.
You're saying, "What kind of project
would have five sign changes?" Let's say
that it's a 30-year project where every
five years you got to come in and update
your machinery. So, you're going to get
negative in year five, negative in year
10. You can have five different internal
rates of return. And what's the rule
with IRR?
If it's greater than your cost of
capital, you accept it. If it's less
than your cost of capital, you reject
it. Let's assume your cost of capital
falls right in the middle.
Project A here has a 6.6% IRR or a
36.55%
IRR.
Okay. Project B has only one IRR, 8.65%.
Let's say your cost of capital is 8%.
You can already see the challenge you're
going to face, right? One IRR is higher
than your cost of capital, the other is
lower.
There are entire books that people write
about what to do
with multiple IRRs.
If that If I wrote that book, it'll have
only one sentence.
If you have multiple IRRs, just go with
the net present value.
Why? There can only be one NPV, no
matter how many cash flow changes there
are.
So, if you have multiple internal rates
of return, they become almost unusable.
I mean, I can give you tricks you can
play, but what's what's You know, this
actually shows up in in investing when
people compute the IRR of a client's
investments because they bring money in
and they take money out. You can have a
dozen different sign changes over a
10-year period. And if you ask me to
compute the IRR, I'm essentially going
to give up very quickly, but I can
always compute an to end up with
So, if you have multiple IRRs, now you
can see why it happens because you have
the cash flow changes.
Just skip IRR and go directly to NPV.
Any questions on multiple internal rates
of return why they happen?
Let's take a second project and here I
think you very quickly see why I get
different answers.
I have two projects.
The first project requires an initial
investment of a million dollars and has
cash flows of 350,000, 450,000, 600, and
750.
The second project has an initial
investment of 10 million
and cash flows that are much bigger.
I compute the NPVs for both projects.
The NPV for project two is almost 1.36
million.
The NPV for project one is 467,000. So,
if I pick based on NPV, project two is
better than project one.
But if I base it on IRR, I get a 33.66%
internal rate of return for project one
and a 21% internal rate of return for
project two.
Now, clearly I'm getting different
choices, but there's a very simple
reason I'm getting different choices,
right?
Derek, what what is it about project one
that's giving me the low NPV and the
higher IRR? IRR?
It's But more importantly, it's a
smaller project, right? Think about it.
Percentage rates of return are always
going to tilt you more towards smaller
projects. It's easier to make a 50%
return when you're investing $10 than
when you're investing 10 million.
So, already you can see larger projects
will have higher NPVs because the dollar
values are going to be higher.
Smaller projects are going to have
higher internal rates of return.
If you open up most corporate finance
textbooks, they're pretty categorical
about which one you should pick.
Which one should you pick in if you in
traditional corporate finance, a higher
NPV project or higher IRR?
Do you remember what we said about
taking a project? What does it do when
you take a positive net present value
project? Your value increases by the net
present value, right?
If I take that to the next step, then I
should be taking project two over
project one
because
I will get a bigger increase in value.
So, here's what I want to do. This half
of the class is going to take project
two. So, you're going to go with the
higher NPV because that's what the
corporate finance textbooks This half of
the class
is going to take project one because the
highest IRR. I want you to think about
at the end of the year what your biggest
concern will be with what your choice
led you to.
So, you took project two, right? You
took 10 million dollars. You took the
project because it has a higher But
let's say your total capital budgeting
project is only uh budget is only 20
million. That's all you can spend.
You've taken half of it and taken this
one project on January 5th of 2025.
What's your biggest worry?
You've used up half your total capital
budgeting no allocation.
What if another great project comes
along that'll give you a 12 million in
initial investment? You can't take it
anymore.
So, your biggest concern if you take the
big net present value project is other
projects coming down you might not take.
Why? Because you don't have enough
capital.
Conversely, if I look at you and you
say, you picked the higher IRR project,
what's your biggest worry? Wade, what's
your biggest worry going to be? My
biggest worry would be
can we find enough projects? Exactly. If
this is the only project you get all
year and there's no guarantee there
will, you got stuck with 19 million
sitting in cash you couldn't invest. You
can see your concerns are different.
When you take based on IRR, you're
worried about, hey, what if other
projects don't come along? If you base
it on NPV, your worry is, what if other
projects come along? And if you think
through it, each of these is going to
lead you to a different outcome.
Why did you have a
a constraint of 20 million on your on
your capital budget?
Because you didn't have access to
capital, right? If you're a company
which has limited access to capital,
you're a small company, you're a private
company. You're in a market where
external capital access is limited.
Do you see where you're going to go?
You're going to go with internal rate of
return because you're worried about the
limits.
In contrast, if you're Apple,
this should never be a reason, right?
You can't complain to me you don't have
enough cash. You have 200 million
sitting around.
If you're Apple, you should always go
with NPV because you don't have capital
constraints.
Whether you go with NPV or IRR is not as
black and white as textbooks make it out
to be.
Technically, I think NPV is a sounder
measure of returns and we'll talk about
why. But I can fully understand if
you're a company with limited capital
access that you go with the internal
rate of return because you want to get
the most bang for your buck.
Any questions?
Okay. So, IRR might be a Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah.
NPV and IRR are good but they're not
good for riskiness. Whoa, whoa, whoa,
wait, wait, wait. NPV doesn't account
for riskiness?
Yeah?
50% of
No, but wait. What did you discount
these cash flows at?
It's a risk-adjusted discount rate,
right? So, if the
your cash flow cash flow in year five
was guaranteed, what discount rate would
you have used?
The risk-free rate, right?
So, when you do NPV, it is the risk is
in your discount rate.
And NPV is a risk-adjusted number. With
IRR, you're technically right. The IRR
doesn't capture the risk, but what do I
compare the IRR to?
A cost of capital, a risk-adjusted rate.
So, both NPV and IRR do incorporate
risk.
They incorporate a very special kind of
risk, the risk you cannot diversify away
as an investor. But they're they're both
risk-adjusted numbers.
But is everybody clear on this choice
between NPV and IRR? It depends very
much on whether you feel you have a
capital rationing constraint. So, let's
step back. Let's think about where
capital rationing constraints come from.
Almost every company you talk to will
claim that they have limited capital.
Some of it comes from the outside,
right? You might not be able to access
capital. Why? Because your markets are
ill-formed. Because banks won't lend you
money. Because equity markets are
difficult to access. Because you're a
private business. In a private business,
where does equity have to come from?
You. You say, I have only so much money.
So, sometimes capital rationing
constraints come from outside.
But if you're a publicly traded company,
sometimes capital rationing constraints
come from within.
I'll give you an example.
There are companies that will refuse to
issue new shares. Not because they
cannot, but if they did, what's going to
happen? What's the bogeyman that every
analyst brings out of the closet when
you issue shares?
Dilution, right? So, basically they're
afraid of dilution. They will not issue
shares.
It's an internal constraint. They choose
not to borrow money. Not because that is
going to somehow put them into distress,
but they don't like to borrow money.
Capital rationing constraints can
sometimes come from outside. They can
come from Is there a difference though
from where they come in?
Let's suppose you take IRR because you
have a capital rationing constraint, but
it's entirely internally imposed because
of what you did. You chose to not raise
equity.
And you're turning away projects as a
consequence, right? Because of this
capital rationing constraint.
I will ask you to take a look at your
constraint. You're so set against
dilution, but look at how many projects
you had to reject last year because you
didn't want to issue shares.
Then let's still choose not to issue the
shares. But anytime you impose a
constraint as a business, you got to ask
yourself what the cost of that
constraint is.
And if you're a company where you're
giving up so much with that constraint,
it might be worth re-examining that
constraint if it's an internal
constraint.
But if you're an Argentine company, this
has nothing to do with you, right? It's
a fact that the market is not allowing
you to raise capital, therefore using
IRR. There I completely understand the
focus on percentage rates of return.
Questions?
Now, one way in which you can stay with
NPV
and bring in the capital rationing
issue.
The problem with the NPV is it's a
dollar value or an absolute value.
If I can somehow scale it to how much
you invested in a project,
I would get a almost a percentage value,
a scaled NPV. It's not high-tech. So,
here's what I'm going to do. I'm going
to take each NPV and divide it by the
initial investment of the project. What
does it do? It tells me how many dollars
of net present value I get per dollar of
investment. It's like a percentage
return. I stay with NPV and I still
factor in a capital rationing
constraint.
So, if you have a capital rationing
constraint, you just don't like to use
internal rate of return for whatever
reason, and you want to stay with NPV, I
can give you a way of bringing in that
capital rationing constraint by saying
it's called a
go with the with the the higher
profitability index, an NPV that's
scaled to your initial investment.
So, you talked about multiple internal
rates of return. Why do they come?
Because cash flows change signs. What to
do if you have them? Just don't use IRR.
You talked about NPV and IRR giving you
different answers when your projects
have different scale. Larger projects
will tend to have higher net present
values. Smaller projects will tend to
have higher percentage rates of return.
Just a scaling effect. Which one should
you adopt? I'm going to ask you, do you
have a capital rationing constraint? In
fact, the company you have in your
project.
I mean, right now you might not be able
to change the way they do I'd like you
to think about should your company use
NPV or IRR? So, what are some of the
things you're going to look at to make
that judgment?
You might look at the size of the
company, smaller companies.
What else? Is there something on the
balance sheet you could look at that you
can confront them with when they say we
have a capital rationing constraint?
Kelly, what do you what might you look
at their balance sheet to see if you
have a capital rationing constraint?
That might actually feed into that
constraint, right? Because if you
borrowed a money, I can understand you
don't want to take projects.
But on the other side of the balance
when I look at their assets, there's
something that'll give away the fact
that they're lying when they say they
have a So, if Apple says they have a
capital rationing constraint,
they have a cash balance, right? If you
look at a company that has 40 billion in
cash, stop talking about capital
rationing constraints.
If you want to use IRR and you want
because you like it, go ahead and do it,
but don't use IRR now because you have
You know, sometimes companies as they
grow hold on to what they used to do
when they were much smaller. Many of
these companies at some point in time
were high-growth companies with lots of
projects, not enough capital.
Of course, they had the capital
rationing constraint. What's happened to
them over time? They've now become much
larger, they've accumulated large cash
balances, the projects have dropped off.
There's a tipping point. Remember that
corporate life cycle that I showed you?
Early in the life cycle, IRR makes more
sense to you, but there will be a
tipping point as your growth starts to
level off where you got to stop and say,
"It doesn't make sense for us to talk in
percentage returns anymore."
12% return might not have looked good
enough for us 10 years ago when we were
a young company with lots of projects,
but today
10% is about as good as it gets, it's
higher than our cost of capital.
I think one reason tech companies end up
with big cash balances is they get
spoiled.
They get spoiled because in their growth
days, in their glory days, they make 30,
40, 50% returns. Then what happens?
You're saying, "Well, if I don't make
30% returns, I'm not going to take
projects."
No wonder you have a 40 billion-dollar
cash balance then.
So, when you look at cash balances, that
might be a sign that you're aging out of
whatever hurdle rate you've been using
artificially
to turn projects away.
One final example on NPV versus IRR.
Here I have two projects, both require
$10 million initial investment.
Different patterns on cash flows. The
first project has high cash flows up
front, lower later. The second project
is low cash flows up front and higher
later. There's a timing difference,
right? But remember, both NPV and IRR
time-weighted measures of return,
they're factoring in
when your cash flows come in.
But here's the puzzle. If you look at
the NPV, it's The NPV of project two is
higher than the NPV of project one.
But in terms of IRR, the reverse
happens.
See if you can figure out why that is.
They're both time-weighted measures of
return.
Why is the internal rate of return
giving you a different answer than the
NPV? Tonmay, you want to try? What is it
about them?
Yeah.
But I thought time weighting should take
care of that, right? So, there must be
some difference in how they're time
weighting the cash flows.
Cuz if I were computing return on
capital to NPV, that's this would be it,
right? The time But here, they're both
time weighting cash flows, but they seem
to be time weighting it differently
because they're arriving at different
conclusions.
So, tell me what it is about
What what's the same disc
So, what's the discount rate I use for
NPV?
Capital. What's the discount rate I use
for IRR?
It's whatever discount rate that makes
my NPV zero, right? When I get cash
flows in year one, this $5 million, what
happens to it?
It gets invested somewhere else, right?
When I use NPV, I implicitly assume
implicitly because we're never explicit
about it that it gets reinvested at what
rate?
The cost of capital. In other words, the
money I'm making in intermediate periods
makes me zero net present value.
Essentially, it earns a fair rate of
return. I can even leave it in cash or
T-bills and earn a T-bill rate.
When I do NPV, I implicitly assume that
the cash flows I get in year one and
year two essentially earn my cost of
capital. In other words, they're not
creating excess value.
But when I use IRR, you know what I
implicitly assume? What do I invest the
year one cash flows at in project A?
At 21.41%.
Do you see why this is inherently a more
dangerous assumption? If I have a great
project and it's a one-time great
project, and I get cash flows in year
one, I magically create another great
project which earns the same rate of
return.
Now, do you see why PE investors love to
use internal rate of return?
Even if their cash flows are right,
which is a big if, and they tell you the
IRR for this project is And let's say
it's a 20-year project, is 30%.
You know why it's a lie? Because the
year cash flows you get in year one,
year two, you somehow have to find other
investments to make at 30%
to earn that 30% rate of return.
NPV assumes you reinvest your cash flows
at the hurdle rate, which is a
risk-adjusted rate and by definition a
rate you can earn in the market right
now. You can put your money in a mutual
fund and earn that rate of return.
But IRR assumes you reinvest the IRR,
which means the higher the internal rate
of return for an investment becomes, the
more suspicious you should become about
that number, especially if it's a
long-term investment, cuz you're making
this
internal assumption about what you can
invest that money at.
So, those of you going to private equity
and hedge funds, watch out for IRRs
because they'll come at you
fast and furious.
And you I mean, one way you can get the
conversation back on steady ground is to
say, "Hey, that 65% IRR you're giving me
on this 20% project, can you please tell
me what other projects you're going to
give me in year one and year two which
will also earn 65%?"
So, differences in assumptions about
reinvestment are inherent. And because
it's implicit, you don't even think
about it.
They're both time-weighted.
And which one you use then will depend
on whether you have this infinite stream
of great projects, in which case go with
the IRR, I don't have a problem with it.
Or if this is more likely to be a one
and done,
in which case you have to be very
careful about assuming that
reinvestment.
So, this NPV versus IRR reinvestment
rate assumption is why corporate finance
textbooks tell you you should always use
the NPV. It's a little bit of an
overreaction. Cuz is there a way I could
fix the IRR
to make it reinvest money at the cost of
capital?
Any ideas? What what's the problem here?
I'm taking my cash flow in year one and
assuming I can make 21.41%, right?
What's my cost of capital? Let's say
it's 12% or 15%. What if I reinvest the
cash flow I get in year one at the cost
of capital, actually explicitly? That's
basically what's called a modified
internal rate of return. It's not rocket
science. You're essentially taking the
IRR and instead of assuming you can earn
the IRR on every single cash flow,
you're assuming you can earn the hurdle
rate.
I'll show you the mechanics of how this
will play out.
You have a project initial investment is
a thousand, 300, 400, 500, and 600. You
take the cash flow in year one, instead
of assuming you reinvest at the at the
IRR, you reinvest at the cost of
capital. Let's say the cost of capital
is 15%. And you keep track of how much
money you will have at the end of year
four. Take the cash flow in year two,
invest it at 15% for two years. Take the
cash flow in year three, invest it 15%
for one year. At the end of the fourth
year, add up all your money. So, think
like an investor whose money is going
into this N bank account,
the end you're going to have $2,160 in
the bank.
Your initial investment is a thousand,
you know you're going to have $2,160,
back out a rate of return, the modified
IRR here will be lower than your IRR
because you're effectively earning only
15% on that money.
So, you can fix NPV for the scaling
problem by doing that profitability
index. You can fix IRR for the
reinvestment problem by doing a modified
IRR.
I, you know, when it comes to NPV versus
IRR, I'm not going to be a purist.
Because when you use IRR, you're 90% of
the way towards me, right? It's a time
I'd much rather use IRR than return on
capital or payback.
You moved 90% of the way towards me. Why
would I push you away by saying, "You're
not perfect, you're not using NPV"? I'll
take what you're comfortable. Maybe you
prefer percentage rates of return, which
I completely understand. And I'll try to
fix at the margin whatever might get you
into trouble, in this case the
reinvestment assumption.
So, that 60% return project the private
equity, in fact, take that 60%,
recompute it using an 8 or 9%
cost of equity, which is what you're
earning right now. It's amazing how
quickly the 60% will start to drop off
to 25, 26, 27%
with that internal rate of return being
replaced by the hurdle rate.
So, any questions on the mechanics of
NPV versus IRR because I'm going to kind
of put it to sleep because, you know,
their entire There's some corporate
finance class we spend two, three, four
sessions talking about NPV versus IRR. I
think you kind of lose the script when
you get there. They're both time
weighted, but it's good to know what
causes them to give you different
rankings and which ones to use. Yes? So,
obviously this is forward-looking and
trying to pick projects for the future,
but what if you were like trying to
measure like backward-looking? Like
would people use IRR to look at past
performance or No, most people use IRR
to measure past performance, but what's
the end game there? What's After you do
that, you can't obviously go back and
fix your past mistakes. What comes out
of that analysis?
You fire your portfolio manager, you
replace him. So, we'll talk about
postmortems. Because both NPV and IRR,
when you look backwards, you're asking a
very different question than we're
looking forward. Remember the sunk
costs? When you're looking forward, sunk
costs should always be ignored. When
you're looking backwards,
I care about sunk costs. So, we'll talk
about what's different about looking
back because there you're doing it for a
different reason.
You're trying to assess was this manager
good for me? Did they pick good
projects? And that's a good question to
ask and answer.
But I think, you know, when you do when
you look at projects, the
forward-looking decision, you're looking
at incremental future cash flows. The
mechanics won't change
when you look backwards, but the end
game is different, right?
So, let's summarize why NPV and IRR give
you different answers. First, for any
project with any set of cash flows,
there will always be a unique NPV.
There's only one NPV.
So, if you show me two NPVs for your
Celsius each project, you've just broken
open finance as we know it, and I'm very
interested in how you got there.
But you can have multiple IRRs.
I don't know whether you've examined
your Celsius each cash flows. I don't
know whether there might be a negative
cash flow in the future and what might
cause it. If it does happen, you know
exactly what's going to You know, the
deceptive thing is if you use the IRR
function in Excel,
it actually comes back with one number
even if there's more than one IRR.
You know how it comes back with one
number?
It makes you guess a number and then it
gives you the number. It's very
deceptive. I'd much rather that Excel
came back and said, "I can't give you a
number. There are two internal rates of
return."
But because it's Excel, it wants to act
like it knows more than it does. So,
don't trust the Excel IRR. That's why I
said do the NPV profile if you're
interested because there you will always
see
the multiple internal rates of return
because you crossed the line once,
twice, three times, as many IRRs as
there are.
Second,
NPV is a measure of dollar surplus or
euro surplus. It's an absolute number.
IRR is a percentage return. So, almost
by definition, bigger projects are more
likely to have larger NPVs. Smaller
projects are more likely to have
percentage rates of return.
If you have capital rationing, you might
go with a percentage rate of return, but
do it for the right reasons.
And third, the two make different
assumptions about what rate you can
reinvest the money at.
NPV assumes you can earn your cost of
capital. Basically, that you make zero
net present value on your intermediate
cash flows.
If you go out and take positive net
present That's all That's icing on the
cake. You can do But effectively, it
doesn't put it into your existing
project, and I think that's the right
thing to do. IRR assumes you can earn
your internal rate of return, and that
can get you into trouble.
So, those are projects with the same
lives.
Let's say you're comparing projects with
different lives. And here I'm going to
use my daughter's kitchen to illustrate.
Every decision she made,
she had to face a choice. She's a school
teacher. She's on a constrained budget.
So, every choice she had to think about.
So, the flooring.
The guy came in and said, "Well, I can
offer you three types of flooring.
They have different costs." And if you
look purely at cost, there was one
choice, but it would usually be a
flooring that would last 7 years versus
6 years. But if you chose a different
kind of flooring,
cost you more, last 15 years. You're
saying, "So what?"
I've been training her on NPV. She's
very resistant to this idea.
But you could take the NPV of the cost
of each one, right? The costs over 7
years. And if you look just at NPV,
you're going to find that the project
with the fewer years is going to have
the lower net present value of cost. You
have fewer years of spending money.
When you're comparing projects with
different lives, you're going to see
this play out. So, let's take a very
simple example. Let's have two projects.
One with a 5-year life and the second
with a 10-year life. Let's assume
they're mutually exclusive. So, if you
take one, you can't take the other. So,
you're trying to decide between a 5-year
project
and you're a 10-year project.
I'm going to give you the cash flows.
Initial investment of a billion, cash
flows of 400 million every year. The NPV
for project one is 442 million. On
project B,
I
spent more up front, 1.5 million, but I
get a 350 million cash flows for 10
years. NPV of 478 million. So, based
purely on NPV,
project B is better than project A,
right?
IRR, you don't have an issue. So, file
that away. IRR will give you a
percentage rate of return, but time
doesn't matter.
If I pick purely on NPV, almost every
single time, you're going to see what
I'm going to tilt with, right? I'm going
to go to the longer life project because
you have more cash flows.
Imagine being Scott Boras, right?
Pete Alonso is your client.
The Mets have been holding out.
And they come to you and say, "We can
give you a 2-year contract
or a 5-year contract." If you just look
at the money you will make over the
entire contract life,
which one's going to give you more total
money?
The 5-year contract. You're getting paid
for 5 years. So, in baseball, what do
people report in addition to the total
contract? They report the payment you're
going to get per year. Common sense
answer, right?
Take the annual amount because that's
going to be comparable, but you can't
compare the total values of two
contracts if one is 3 years and one is 5
years.
So, I'm going to give you the two ways
of dealing with this different life
problem.
In this one, there's an easy fix.
It does require an implicit assumption.
We'll see what that implicit assumption
is. The first project is a life of 5
years.
The second project is a life of 10
years, right?
So, what could I do on the first project
to make it comparable to the second
project?
I can do it twice.
There is an implicit assumption, you
know? So, when you look at project life,
you're already going to see NPV is
higher. The implicit assumption is in
year five, I'm going to be able to
replicate this project and do it a
second time.
If I just look at annual payments on
contracts, you know what this lead
agents to do, right? They'll always pick
the shorter term contract because if you
if you assume you can replicate the
shorter term contract, what's the
difference between signing a two But
what's the danger Scott Boras gets you
into as a player when he signs a shorter
term contract? At the end of 2 years,
you go to sign,
but your ERA has soared through the roof
or your hitting average has dropped off,
your second 2-year contract. This is the
reason why Boras wants 10-year
contracts. Lock a pitcher in for 10 Max
Fried, I like the guy, but he's 29 years
old. I know exactly what I'll be feeling
in about 6 years looking at Max Fried,
I'd have signed him for too much
on a per year basis. But assuming you
can keep replicating the projects,
you'll always go with the shorter term
because you'll get pretty much the same
cash flows. And if you take the net
present value of doing project A twice
versus doing project B once,
those NPVs are comparable.
You're saying, "This is good. This is
what I'm going to do on the quiz." Okay,
let's say that you decide you're going
to do this on the quiz. There's an easy
way I can get you
if that's my end game. It's not my end
game, but if I wanted to, I could give
you a 7-year project and a 9-year
project to compare.
How would you make them comparable then?
You'll have to take the 7-year project
nine times.
It's a nice thing about working with
prime numbers. And the 9-year project
seven times. You'll have a 63-year
combined project. Imagine sitting there
computing cash flows for the next 63
years on a 30-minute quiz.
There must be an easier way, right?
And there is. In fact, I gave you kind
of that answer when I said you compare
the annual amount.
One easy way is to just take the NPV and
divide by the life of the project.
I could take the 478 and divide by 10. I
could take the the 420 442 and divide by
five. But what would I be missing if I
just computed divided the NPV by the
number of years?
NPV is time weighted, right?
Dividing by the number of years, you're
not factoring in time. So, I'm just
going to add one layer. It's not even
that sophisticated. I'm going to take
the NPV and ask myself a question. What
would I require on an annual basis
to get the same NPV? If you take the 442
million, remember it's a 5-year project,
122 million dollars every year for the
next 5 years. The present value of that
at the 12% cost of capital will give you
the same NPV.
So, I've taken the first NPV and
converted into what's called an
equivalent annuity. Essentially, how
much annual cash flow would I need to
get that NPV?
The second project, 478 million, is a
10-year project. With a 12% cost of
capital, that annuity works out to 84.6
million.
I'm going to go with a higher equivalent
annuity cuz it gives me more Implicitly,
I'm making the same assumptions I do in
replication.
But I don't have to go through the
process on the 7 and the 9-year project.
You can take the MPVs of the two
projects, convert the first project into
an annuity.
So, it's as simple as entering the PV
and looking for your payment to give you
the same present value.
So, think of it as a slightly more
sophisticated version of just averaging
over time
because it factors in the time value.
Like this is what I worked out. I told
her to do it, but my daughter would not
do it. So, I took her, you know, uh
countertops and I worked out this is how
much you're paying up front. This is how
much it costs you on an annual basis.
Cuz she has a time value of money and
she has to factor them to a decision
making.
So, when you think about making choices
and we do this on a daily basis, should
I go with the less expensive car or the
more expensive car assuming that they
have different lifetimes?
This can be a way in which you can break
the tie by converting net present value,
which is a lump sum, into an annual
amount.
Any questions
on converting into annuities? Try this
out on your calculator, computer,
whatever you use for your annuities
because until you do it, the mechanics
might mess you up. So, make sure you can
convert a present value to an annual
amount, but at least the intuition is I
can compare annual amounts, but I can't
compare MPVs. Yes.
Annuity? Oh, that's the
that's the annuity you're looking for.
The payment if that's the I don't know
what the calculator lingo would be, but
in traditional calculators this is
usually the PMT button, the payment
button. So, basically I'm looking I'm
entering the PV, the the the life, and
the discount rate looking for the
payment. So, that's effectively what I'm
doing. And that converts a present value
into a payment, right?
So, we've talked about all these
different ways to pick projects, right?
We can look at return on investment,
whether return on equity or return on
invested capital.
We can look at payback, very simple and
very intuitive. How many years
will it take for me to get or discounted
payback? We want to cover the amount
with time value of money. You can look
at NPV and we talked about all the
the layers to NPV. It's a dollar value,
that's kind of a prom, but it's value
added. It factors in this reasonable
assumption about intermediate cash
flows. You can look at IRR, percentage
number that might be attractive, but it
comes with this cost of reinvestment
rate assumptions.
Or you can use this PI, profitability
index, or you can add modified internal
rate of return to the mix. Let's say
you're the CFO of a company
and you're trying to decide which of
these approaches you're going to adopt
as your metric across the company.
Don't tell me all of the above. Yeah, I
know you're tempted to say, "Why can't
we do all of the six?" Because
ultimately you will have to choose,
right? That's So, that's not a
tiebreaker. You can do all of the
calculations, but one of them has to
rule.
What are some of the things that will go
into
you
you look at to make that judgment?
First, will it matter whether you're a
private whether you're a family-owned
business and you're the owner or or a
public company?
Why why might that be? What What if
you're
What Why that make a difference?
Because first, it's your wealth tied up.
You got this total beta issue. You can't
bring in more equity, you're limited
capital.
You're saying, "I'm going to have to
make the best percentage rate of
return."
If you're a public company, you have
access to capital at least if you choose
to use it. So, you might be more likely
to go with NPV as a public company as
opposed to private business. Does it
matter where you're in the life cycle?
As we talked about, young companies
early in the life cycle, you should
probably go for the most bang for your
buck, percentage rates of return. As you
mature as a company,
when can you use accounting returns? As
you get more mature, the NPV rules and
the accounting return on capital rules
will tend to converge. So, if you're a
mature company and you insist on using
accounting return on capital to pick
projects, you'll probably pay a smaller
price than a younger company.
So, when you work with a company and
they use a a decision rule that is
different than what you would expect,
ask some questions. Maybe there's a good
reason they're using IRR
or even accounting return. And you can
suggest tweaks to it to bring in time
value and things that they're not
factoring in.
But there's no one answer that's going
to cut across every company and every
business because it depends on your
characteristics.
Saying, "Well, what's happening in the
market affect me?" I mean, I use the
example of the last quarter of 2008.
What happened in the last quarter of
2008? You have a market crisis. What
does a market crisis do? It affects your
access to capital, right? You can't go
back. Venture capitalists have stopped
giving you money.
Even if you've been using NPV until now,
you might say, "Now I have to shift to
IRR cuz we live in a very different
setting."
So, be flexible. Be adaptable. Don't be
dogmatic saying NPV or nothing because
you're more likely than not get nothing.
So, there's this survey that I've looked
at what companies use and the results
are actually pretty interesting. So,
this is a comparison of 2001 to 2022,
large versus small companies, right?
So, percentage of companies that use and
you can see that the numbers add up to
well over 100%, which tells you what? A
lot of companies do all of the above.
So, it doesn't quite tell you what what
they what dominates, but at least on a
percentage basis, NPV and IRR at the
top.
I have a survey from 1976
and accounting return on capital was on
top. So, over the last 50 years there's
been a shift
towards time value adjusted measures of
return. I guess that's good news. Now,
50 years of corporate finance is
sticking.
But as you go down, you see scenario
analysis. I'm not even sure what that
means. I'll be quite honest.
How is that a metric? I mean, you can
take all of these approaches and do
scenarios. You can do the NPV under five
scenarios, which tells me that CFOs say
scenario analysis is mistaking what you
do with the metric
with the metric itself.
Surprisingly high percentage of firms
still think about payback.
It's the most primitive of approaches,
right?
And you know what?
Post-1980s,
the use of payback actually surged and
dropped off.
And one of the reasons was leveraged
buyouts and debt at a lot of companies.
Do you see why having debt will make you
much more interested in payback?
You have a lot of debt. What's your
first concern? Survival. You need to get
the cash flows to pay off the debt. So,
when you have to pick between two
projects, you're going to go with the
project with the front-ended cash flows
over the So, there is again a good
reason why these approaches hang in
there.
Return on invested capital, book return,
big if you see the numbers, big
difference, you know, between 2020 So,
you can look at 2022 and
far fewer firms actually use
return on invested capital.
I'm sorry, far more firms use return on
invested capital. And this is I think
that that when I told you it became a
magic bullet and people going around
saying, "No, return on invested capital
rules."
So, you can go down the list and you can
see profitability index. Real options
we'll come back and talk about because
that's kind of this magical buzzword
again that people have used to pick
projects. Okay?
Simulation analysis again, scenario
analysis. Simulation are not metrics,
they're ways in which you can compute
the metrics. And finally, adjusted
present value, which I'll hold off till
we get to capital structure cuz the way
it's practiced is such
a bastardized version of what it should
be that at this point I'm not even sure
what it means.
So, adjusted present value is really
capital structure approach. Keep that
separate.
But clearly, they're all over the place.
And many of these companies you see five
or six metrics reported for a project.
Which a dangerous place to leave
decision makers in
cuz you know what's going to happen,
right? Your biases are going to play out
in how you pick projects.
So, any questions about the mechanics of
all of the different metrics? Each comes
with pluses and minuses. Factor them in
and pick it.
I also want now to talk about side costs
and side benefits. When I talked about
the Rio Disney theme park, I acted like
it was a standalone project, which got
cash flows and essentially you looked at
the theme park and just the theme park.
But when Disney opens a theme park, it
gets some side benefits, right?
So, when they opened to you know, Euro
Disney in Paris, it actually saw a jump
in
people coming to Disney movies in Europe
because you now had this new audience
you were drawing on. It might increase
the sale of merchandise because you have
a theme park now.
So, there are side benefits you often
get from taking an investment.
Are there side costs sometimes from
taking an investment as well?
Yeah?
The side costs might include that you
have to take resources you already own,
people who work in Burbank and send them
to Paris because they have to run that
theme park. It might be physical assets
you own
that you're transferring to this theme
park.
There are both side benefits and side
costs and what drives me crazy is when
they're treated as garnish. What does
that mean?
Let's say you're a you're you're Disney
or any movie company, you look at a
movie numbers and you say, "This movie
standing alone
has a negative net present value."
So, that's the end of the game, right?
You don't take a movie. And then
somebody pipes up say, "But there could
be side benefits." Okay.
We should take the project. Now, I'm not
okay.
If you're going to talk side benefits,
your job is to bring them into the
analysis. If you're going to talk side
costs, you have to use it explicitly.
It's not going to be easy to do. Some of
these side benefits and side costs are
are fairly difficult to get your hands
on. But if you're going to make a
decision based on them, it's your
obligation to bring them into the
numbers.
So, I'm going to start with this notion
of what I call an opportunity cost. It's
kind of a generic word. Anytime you use
something that could be used elsewhere,
right? But I'm going to use it in a very
specific sense.
When s- especially large companies take
projects, they often take things they
already own, resources, facilities, and
they use it on the project.
And because they already own it, you
know what the easy
way to deal with it is, right? We
already own it. There is no cash flow.
So, we're going to ignore it.
But that doesn't make any sense, right?
When you use something on a project,
there is always a cost, and your job is
to assess what that cost is.
You could sell that
asset
if that's feasible.
When I walk through the Disney Burbank
headquarters, all these buildings, many
of them are only half full now.
Why? More stuff is being done off, you
know, at home.
So, you're saying there's excess
building, the additional building there.
Could you sell it? Probably not because
it's right in the middle of your
headquarters.
If you can't sell it, maybe you can rent
or lease it out like, you know, let
somebody else use it.
Or you can ask yourself, if I use this
building, what do I give up later? In
other words, there's always a cost, and
the question you got to ask is, what is
that cost? How do I bring it into the
decision?
So, let's take a s- a very simple
example of an opportunity cost. Let's
assume that Disney owns land in Rio
already. Don't ask me how they bought
the land. They must have bought it for
some other reason. It's been sitting out
there.
And if the Rio Disney Remember, you
haven't made the decision on the Rio
Disney theme park yet. If it gets taken,
that land will be used to house the
office buildings for the theme park.
They already own the land. They don't
have to pay for the land.
But I'm going to add a couple of
qualifiers here for you to make a
decision.
If they don't take the Rio Disney theme
park, they have an opportunity. They
might not use it to sell the land for 40
million.
But it's land they bought a few years
ago for 5 million. So, the book value of
the land is 5 million. They can sell it
for 40 million.
And I want you to return to the Rio
Disney theme park assessment, right? So,
you're looking at the cash flows. And
now I'm telling you they're going to use
this land.
What
And the question I have is specifically
about the number to attach to this land
I'm using. Should I ignore the cost
because Disney already owns the land?
Technically, they don't have a cash
flow, right?
But is there an opportunity cost?
Yeah, you can sell the land.
In which case, what do I show as my cost
of the land? I could show the 5 million,
which is the book value of the land.
Is that Is that going to fix the
Is that my opportunity cost? No, I'm not
going to sell the land. I could sell it
for 40 million.
It looks like I'm getting close to the
answer. But if I sell it for 40 million,
I will have a loose end to tie up,
right? I sold it for 40 million. I
bought it for 5 million. There will be a
$35 million
gain
gain on which I have to pay some kind of
tax. Let's say I have capital gains tax
of 20%. When you want to think through
these things, think them all the way
through. In this case, you sell the land
for 40 million. You're going to have a
35 million capital gain. 20% tax at 7
million.
In my Rio Disney analysis, in my initial
investment, I'm going to show a minus 33
million.
You're saying, "Where is that minus 30?"
That is my opportunity cost of using
land that I could have sold elsewhere
and collected the 33 million.
Now, let's take a trickier exercise,
Remember Bookscape? Retail firm.
Let's assume that they're getting
outsold because a lot of people are
buying their books online.
So, Bookscape decides it's going to
create this online retail venture on the
side, and it's asked you to assess
whether it makes sense. So, here's what
they're going to If they start this
venture, they're going to make revenues
of 1 and 1/2 million in year two. And
ex- And And And And that number is going
to grow over time at 10%. The costs of
the books you sell will be 60% of your
revenues. So, I've kind of given you
what they will make on this online
venture. Okay. The initial investment
you will need
will be to set up the computers, the
online will be a mi- So, you're
investing a million dollars. You're
going to make revenues of 1 and 1/2
million in year two. And essentially,
the the expected profits from that.
You will have to pay some employees to
directly run this online venture. Let's
say the direct costs are going to be
150,000 in year one and grow 10% a year.
So, I've given you the revenues, the
cost of the books, the salaries.
And there will be a working capital
requirement specific to this online
venture.
Maybe everybody orders Harry Potter
books, and that's all they order. You
need hundreds and hundreds of copies.
That working capital is going to be 10%
of revenues with the investments made at
the beginning of each year. So, I'm
sticking to the script on items like
working capital by telling you when you
have to make the investment.
And the tax rate on your income is 40%.
Let's work out what the cash flows will
be
on this online venture.
Before I do that, though, let me get the
cost of capital nailed down. You're
saying, "But we already have a cost of
cap for Bookscape." We have a cost of
cap for Bookscape
for its traditional physical bookstore.
But this is going to be an online
venture. Let's say at least at the time
that I was looking at this, online
retail was riskier than brick-and-mortar
retail.
But that you're going to keep the same
debt ratio you did for the rest of your
business.
The
the the unlevered beta.
Remember, I looked at total beta because
you're essentially looking at the total
risk here, is 3.02. You're getting a
much higher cost of equity because you
got a higher unlevered beta, therefore a
higher levered beta. The cost of equity
is going to be 21.5%.
Much higher discount rate. But again,
we're just following exactly the script
we've done in every project, right? We
estimate the cash flows. We come up with
the discount rate for the project based
on what risk there is in the project. My
cost of capital
is 18%. Much, much higher than the 12%
plus or the 10.3% early that I got as a
cost of cap for Bookscape as a company.
Riskier project, higher cost of capital.
I'm almost set
to look at the NPV for the project.
Here are my cash flows. I know a lot of
numbers in the page. My revenues build
up 1 and 1/2 million to 2.2 million over
the next 4 years.
I'm going to assume that at the end of 4
years, you're going to wrap up the
project and get salvage value. I'll ask
you in a in a couple of minutes what I
would have done differently if I assumed
this project would continue forever.
I estimate the expenses. Now, labor,
materials, depreciation. I come up with
an operating income.
I make starting to make money right from
the beginning, but it's building up over
time. I can make more money. I get
after-tax operating income. And then I
go through the process of converting to
cash flows. It's a very Well, now, the
process should be a pretty familiar one.
You add depreciation. Why? Because it's
a non-cash expense.
You subtract our change in working
capital.
Why? Because, you know,
it affects your cash flows. I'm taking
cruel earnings and making to cash flows.
And because I'm wrapping up the project
at the end, I look at my salvage value.
The salvage value here is entirely the
working capital being returned. There's
no physical asset salvage value because
the million dollars I invested up front
was in computers. And by the time I get
to year four,
have them good.
But essentially, I'm running the project
into the ground. I'm getting my earnings
and cash flows. Let me pause right there
and ask a question. If I had decided to
assess this project as an ongoing
project,
what are some of the changes you'd
expect to see in my numbers? First, at
the end of year four, instead of a
salvage value, what should I have?
A terminal value that reflects
But for the first 4 years, given that I
want this project to go on forever,
what else should you expect to see?
Should you expect to see reinvestment of
some of that money back because I can't
run things into the ground. So, what
you're probably going to see is a
capital expenditure that shows up every
year because I want to keep this project
going.
My cash flows will reflect my choice on
how I decide to run the project. Here,
it's a finite life project. I run it
into the ground. I compute the net
present value. The net present value I
get at an 18.12%.
is 76,000
375. That's good, right? Greater than
zero.
But there are two things I forgot to
tell you about this project. The first
is
the general manager for the store is
being asked to look after this project
as well. And she comes back and says,
"Look, this is a lot of work.
You need to pay him a lot more to do
it." So, let's assume that because of
this project,
you're going to have to increase her
salary.
And this is going to be a tricky one.
When the project ends after year four,
what are you going to do?
You're going to reduce it. Good luck
with that. No.
But in this case, I'm going to increase
the salary. There's an incremental
effect because of this project of
$20,000 a year. The second is
when you look at um
at this the the office space you need
for the You're going to utilize an
existing office space in your building.
But by doing this, you got to move the
stuff that's in there to some storage
space, which is going to cost you $1,000
to rent. Again, an incremental effect of
the project. So, you're going to have to
pay the general manager $20,000 more a
year, and you're going to have Should
those be factored into my net present
value?
Yeah, they're side costs.
Now, a question, what discount rate
should I use to discount those cash
flows, right?
Cuz the 18.12% was the online venture.
You know, if I take the same 18.12%
I have some, you know, questions about
whether I should be using 18.12%. The
present value of those additional
expenses I'm going to have because of
this project work out to be, you know,
about four if you think about 34,352.
That's just the present value of $21,000
you know, growing at the inflation rate
over time. You subtract that out from
your net present value, you come up with
an NPV of 40,430.
The project is still good, but not as
good as I thought it was going to be.
If I had to pay my general manager
$80,000 more a year,
the project would have become a negative
one. If we're going to talk side costs,
we have to talk specifics.
Cuz otherwise it's a fuzzy number,
right? It could lower my net present
value, but does it lower it enough to
make a decision?
In fact, if you don't like to treat side
costs separately, you can bring them
into your cash flows. All I've done here
is taking my original cash flows,
brought in the extra amount I have to
pay the GM, the general manager to be
there, and the thousand dollars storage
cost into my cash flows, done one
discounting, I'll get exactly the same
answer. One thing about NPVs is you can
actually take pieces and do them
separately.
And at the end add them up.
Now, I don't want to get too specific,
but in Celsius each you have the Celsius
each revenues cash flows, but you have a
side benefit, right? What's the side
benefit?
You're going to sell more Celsius
beverages.
You can bring the Celsius beverage
numbers into your cash flows, do one net
present value, or you can keep them
separate, do the Celsius each
separately, the Celsius beverages.
You're saying, why would I do one over
the other? If you're going to use the
same discount rate, you're going to get
the same answer either way. But if
you're going to use different discount
rates in the two, this gives you the
flexibility of using different discount
rates.
So, when you have side costs, don't talk
about them. Bring them into your
analysis, see if it changes your
decision.
What about side benefits? Uh before I do
that, one final side costs. And this is,
you know,
You know, often when companies take
investments, if they have excess
capacity on the computer server, on data
systems, on storage, they often use some
of that excess capacity
for a project. And the rationale usually
is, it's excess capacity, we're not
using it. Therefore, using it now is
costless. What's the big deal?
What's the big deal of using excess
capacity?
Well, basically you use more of your
capacity, and if at some point in time
you're going to run out of capacity,
this is going to happen sooner rather
than later if you've used up some of the
excess capacity. Think it through,
right? Remember we talked about what
will happen if the project is taken,
what will happen if the project is not
taken. Think it through what that cost
will be.
Because that's got to be brought into
your analysis. You can't view excess
capacity as free just because you've
already paid for it.
Because there is always a consequence.
So, when you think about the framework
you're going to use is ask yourself,
what will happen to my capacity usage if
I take the project, what will happen if
I don't take the project. The answer is
going to stare you in the face as to
what the cost is
of using up excess capacity.
So, any if you want to come up with
creative side costs that come from
projects, you know, throw them in there
because you want to figure out a way to
bring them into the cash flows.
Is there a side cost to Disney Plus
producing this endless stream of
Avengers shows? I'm enjoying the
Daredevil episodes I've watched so far.
Cuz that was one of my favorite shows.
That Is there you think a side cost
to Disney Plus?
What if the Avengers movies have had
actually had a couple of Avengers movies
that haven't made
a billion dollars? It was like
guaranteed every time.
It might be this is a bad movies, but
there's also possibility that you just
have too much Avengers stuff out there,
right? That you're diluting the basic
to begin with. You know, this is
especially true with the Avengers, you
have a multiverse universe.
Already it's pretty confusing cuz you
don't know who's alive, who's dead,
which particular version of the universe
you're in. Now you have shows which put
you into other versions of the universe
at I am I'm a Avengers fan. I have no
idea where I am in time or space. I
expect Thanos to show up any day now.
I want him to. He's one of my favorite
characters. But in the
and I think the cost here is you might
get Disney Plus subscribers by doing
this.
But I do think you're reducing the value
of the franchise movies.
And if you're Disney, you've got to
seriously think about that cost. I think
they're aware of it now.
Because I think one of the first things
Iger did when he came in after Chapek
approved like 12 different Avengers
spin-offs and 10 different Star Wars
spin-offs, he said, there is a cost here
that we're feeling as a company. We got
to slow the process down.
But if you're looking at one of these
shows for Disney Plus, not only do you
have to worry about how do I figure out
the additional benefits, you got to
bring that side cost in.
I want to talk about one other aspect of
a side cost
that's many businesses I think have a
tough time dealing with, right?
When you open the Rio Disney theme park,
we estimated the revenues by estimating
how many people would come to the theme
park and what they would pay, right? But
I never stopped and asked the question,
would they have come to a Disney theme
park anyway?
You're saying, what are you talking
about?
Well, a lot of if you go to especially
to Orlando,
a large percentage of the people in
front of you in line are from Latin
America because getting from, you know,
Sao Paulo or Santiago to Orlando is
actually pretty, you know, it's it's
pretty easy.
So, maybe some of those people were
coming to Orlando. Now that you've
opened a Rio Disney theme park, they're
going to come to Rio instead. You're
saying, so what? Is that revenue then
truly incremental?
In other words, should I be counting all
the revenues? But if 20% of the people
would have gone to a Disney theme park
already, should I be counting only the
80%? It's a hugely consequential
decision, right? Cuz if I make it only
80%, what's going to happen? My revenues
are going to be lower.
My earnings and cash flows are going to
be lower. I'm just going to open fewer
theme parks
or take fewer investments if I worry
about cannibalization. You're saying
that's the right thing to do.
Is it though? Is there a consequence to
counting only the 80% that I have to
think through?
Why are they coming to Rio rather than
going to Orlando? It's more convenient,
right?
What if
Universal opens a theme park? I know and
this is going to be tricky. And instead
of taking your kids or you promised them
you're going to go to a Disney theme
park, but you land up in Universal Rio
and you tell your kids, you know,
there's no Mickey here, but there's
Harry Potter.
It might not be perfect and this is
going to become a factor in whether you
consider it. You might end up losing
this 20%.
to a competitor. I don't think it's
going to happen with theme parks.
In which case,
I might count only the 80% saying, oh or
the the the
the 100% saying, where are they going to
go? But the more I worry about
competitors eating into my I'm going to
keep the entire amount saying, if I
don't do it, somebody else will
cannibalize me.
Now, every time a Starbucks opened in
the neighborhood. Now they're closing,
but there's a day, you know, every month
there'd be a new Starbucks
within four or six blocks of the other
Starbucks. The question I would always
ask myself is,
how many people coming into that
Starbucks would have gone into the other
Starbucks? Starbucks was a company that
mastered cannibalizing itself.
But they kept opening stores because
clearly they were looking at the total
revenues per store.
And as a consequence, they ended up with
too many stores, and then every five or
six years they shut stores down.
But this is something you're going to
see in any kind of chain business where
you're thinking about, should I open the
next restaurant? Should I open the next,
you know, whatever retail store? How
much of that revenue comes I the
the more protected you are from
competition, the more you have to factor
in the cannibalization. Reduce your
sales because you're going to get those
sales anyway.
The more open you are to competition,
competition can come in,
you might have to count the numbers
because you have no choice. If Starbucks
doesn't open that store five blocks from
now, Coaster, Third World Coffee, or
whoever else will open the store closer
to you, and you don't you're too lazy to
walk six blocks, you'll walk the two
blocks.
Competition is going to be a big factor
in whether you consider this
cannibalization or not. So, if you feel
you're completely protected against
cannibalization, count only the 80%. The
20% that you would have, you know,
you're going to get anyway, right? But
if you're in a business where there's
lots of competition,
then act like you get 100% even though
some of it is your own customers because
you're
your competition.
Any questions on cannibalization? Yes,
Kelly.
You know, Disney
You know, Disney knows a lot more about
you than you realize, right? I mean, in
a sense, you know, you come in, you're
you know, you There's a lot of
information you gave Disney when you
bought your ticket. They know who their
repeat customers are and where they're
coming from. At least They might not
know you by by name,
but they know in terms of composition
where the tourists are coming from. So,
it is a guess, but my guess is that
Disney knows pretty much how much of
their Orlando theme park attendance is
coming from different parts of the
world.
Finally, let's talk about synergy.
The definition of synergy is two
entities coming together are able to
create additional cash flows.
And with Disney, you can see synergy
show up in every conceivable way, right?
They have those five How many theaters
do they have in New York? Four or five?
You know, whatever it is. Constantly
running Beauty and the Beast
17 years, 20 years, Lion King for 25
years.
I'm not sure those theaters by
themselves
make money for Disney.
But with Disney, it's not just about how
much money you make on the investment.
It's the ripple effects of what they do
in merchandise and theme parks.
Right? In fact, one of Disney's biggest
concerns, if you've been to a Disney
theme park recently, the attendance is
becoming a little too adult.
Too many grownups.
Why? Because it's too expensive, right?
You take pay $160
to go into a theme park with a
6-year-old, you know exactly what's
going to happen.
Midday, your 6-year-old is going to
crash and burn. You got to leave the
theme park for 5 hours to get them to
take a nap. And while they're napping,
say, "Oh my god,
that was $15 per hour of the nap."
So, what do you do? You drag the kid
through from 9:00 a.m. to 7:00 p.m.
saying, "You're going to enjoy this come
hell or high water."
And the problem with the attendance
getting too adult is the reason Disney's
brand name is where it is is because
kids came in when they were four, five.
I mean, I I go with my grandkids. I look
at the theme park through their eyes.
Right? They're going to be Disney fans
for life, but they're lucky because
their father works for Disney, the
tickets are free, they go like 25 times
a year. Right? But if your kid If kids
are not coming into the theme park,
there's a ripple effect you're going to
feel maybe not now,
but 30, 40, 50 years from now.
Disney, I hope is thinking seriously
about this problem because there are
fixes, right? Maybe you'll have two-tier
prices.
Maybe if you're 22 years old
old and you try to come in buy a ticket
and it's just you, we turn you away.
Saying, "No, no, we don't belong in the
theme park." What are you going to do?
No.
I know it means turning away people
affecting but it's I think an issue that
and it's a synergy effect that they're
thinking about further down.
So, the way this shows out is if there
are side benefits, when you do the NPV
and you've not captured the side
benefits, you're understating the value
of this investment.
So, the question is, first, should I
bring these side benefits in?
And two, if I decide to bring the side
benefits in, how do I capture them?
So, let let's go back to the Harman
Audio example because clearly there were
side benefits. That's why Tata Motors
was thinking of buying Harman Audio. Oh,
first, let me look at the the Bookscape
example, then we'll come back to the
Harman Audio. Let's assume that
Bookscape is thinking about adding a
cafe.
Why? Because, you know, people drink
coffee, maybe they'll hang around and
buy more books. That was the original
idea behind Borders adding
Let's say you're going to you're going
to add a cafe and I work through the
cash flows. So, there's my initial
increased revenues, I've my initial
investment, but basically, the bottom
line is the net present value of this
cafe standing alone
is negative.
You're saying, "I'm not going to open
the cafe." And then I say, "You know
what? If you open the cafe, we will sell
more books." It's It's the onus should
be on me
to show that. But maybe I run a test
market to see how many people kind of
buy books and basically And let's say
that I could tell you how much your book
sales will increase and the profits and
cash flows you will get from that are.
You might open the cafe even though it's
standing alone, it's a negative net
present value investment because the
side benefits tip you over.
Of course, if that's the case, then I'm
going to ask you, is there another way I
can deliver those side benefits? Because
in in many ways, the cafe becomes an
initial investment that allows you to
get those side benefits.
So, side benefits should be factored in.
Sometimes, as in this case, they're easy
to do. Sometimes, they're messier
to bring in.
But it's not fair after an analysis to
tell me there's side benefits, tell me
not tell me what they are, and ask me to
override my number crunching.
So, now let's go back to the Tata
Motors. If you remember, when I valued
Harman Audio as a standalone company,
the value I arrived at
was about 2.476 for the operating asset
and 2.7 million for the equity in the
firm. The stock was actually trading at
5.2 million. So, if you just look at
those numbers, it's a bad investment,
right?
So, we're at the Tata Motors meeting, I
bring up the numbers that we shouldn't
do this acquisition.
And then you say, "But there could be
potential synergies. The reason we're
doing this is because we think
by buying Harman Audio, we can improve
the audio experience in our cars and
sell more cars." Of course, the onus is
on me to convince you to do that.
So, let's assume that by doing this, you
will be able to sell more cars. But
let's be realistic, it's not going to
happen overnight. It's going to take you
3 years to bring Harman Audio into your
cars. And after that, you're going to
generate 10 billion in after-tax
operating income as additional after-tax
operating income because you sell more
cars, primarily in India.
Jaguar Land Rovers are already, we know,
you know, but this is primarily for your
Indian sales and it's going to matter
when you think about the discount rate
I'm going to apply.
And it's going to grow at 4% a year in
perpetuity. Yeah.
Rupees, yeah. Yeah.
So, basically, 10 billion rupees in
additional,
you know, after-tax operating. So, the
question is, is the present value of
that additional income you're going to
make from selling your cars greater than
that negative net present value you get
from paying 2.8 million dollars more
than the market price?
Let's work it out. First, in terms of
risk, the business here is still the
automobile business, right? You've now
taken So, the beta that I'm going to use
is the beta for car companies, not the
beta for audio companies. The geographic
risk comes from where I think I can get
those additional sales. And as I said, I
think these sales are primarily going to
be in India. So, I'm going to use the
equity risk premium for India. And in
terms of debt ratio, I'm going to stick
with the existing debt-to-cap ratio.
So, the cost of capital that I'm using
to compute these synergies is very
different than the cost of capital I
used to value
Remember when I valued Harman Audio, I
did everything in dollars, I used the
equity risk premium for the company.
Here, I'm focused on where the synergies
get delivered.
So, if you look at the cost of capital
I'm going to use in rupee terms because
I want to work in rupees,
it reflects a beta for automobile
companies, the debt ratio of Harman
Audio, and the equity risk premium
for India as a country.
So, much higher cost of capital.
Use a 13.63%. The value that I get,
assuming the 10,000 in after-tax
operating income essentially stretches
into perpetuity, is about 70.7 billion.
I'm still way below where I need to be,
but I've brought synergy in. So, when
you said there are synergies, I'm going
to value the synergy and say, "Even with
the synergy brought in, which is about
1.18 billion, I'm still well below the
market cap." So, what's my advice to
you?
Even with the synergies, this deal
doesn't make sense.
In my valuation class, I spend a session
talking about synergy.
Talking about the value of synergy.
You can value synergy, but the reason so
many acquisitions go off the rocks is
rather than valuing synergy and paying
for it, it becomes a plug variable.
What's a plug variable? You go and buy
Harman Audio anyway.
You talk about synergy, you never put a
number on it. And you say, "I paid the
extra price because of synergy."
That's not fair. If you're going to talk
about synergy, you have to bring those
considerations into your cash flows.
I mean,
you have the ammunition now to push back
against
buzzwords and BS and stuff we use after
the fact to kind of justify decisions we
want to take anyway.
I know you're going to be the skunk in
the at the party because everybody wants
the deal to go through.
But somebody's got to talk about the
numbers. You're going to pay this extra
amount, where is it coming from? What is
it worth?
So, synergies, side costs, all of those
are part of that spectrum of things you
want to talk about, but bring them into
your numbers because without bringing
them into the numbers,
it's very easy to fall into that
buzzword phenomenon. Let's agree.
You're going to see this with AI, I
guarantee you. Somebody's going to come
up with a project and then your net
present value is going to be negative,
but somebody's going to say, "But this
will let us get into AI." Okay.
How? Where?
In what form? It's healthy to actually
start to demand tangible answers to
those questions because without them,
you're going to take the project anyway
and then be disappointed 5, 10 years
later because you're not seeing the cash
flow show up.
Any questions on synergies, side costs?
So, be creative. Think about all the
things that kind of ripple around when
you take a project and try to bring them
as best as you can into your analysis.
You're going to be wrong in your
estimates, but as long as you're not
biased, you're going to be okay. In next
session, we talk about looking at past
projects.
This is exactly what I'm going to
do. You know, you when I look at your
past NPVs on projects,
I can almost guarantee you that the
actual NPVs on these projects would not
have matched your past NPVs. Some you're
going to come in above, some you're
going to come in below.
But in every one of them, your original
NPV when you took the project is higher
than the actual NPV you got on the
project. What's that telling me?
There's bias in this process, and I've
got to dig through to see why it's
happening.
So, I'm going to leave you with that.
Next You know, Wednesday we're going to
start with the Celsius Heat case. So,
bring your numbers with you. Uh but turn
in your case before. You know, you can
bring the numbers and compare we we you
can compare it as I go through my
numbers, but don't freak out if our
numbers are different. Cuz on some
variables at least I gave you room to be
different.
Yes.
You bet.
Davos and Davos, right? Take a look at
the people who go to Davos. It's an
amazing pile of them. Let me show you.
You know, I I'm not a conspiracy
theorist, but I can see why people feel
that the world is being run by hidden
powers that are And when you do that,
the power of democracy fades, right? You
say, "What Why do I waste my time?" And
especially among young people,
it really is you know, it's really is
troublesome that you're eating away at
the core of their faith
in we control our own future if we work
for the right things. You know, they
say, "Well, it doesn't make a
difference. My school loans are still
going up. I'm still having, you know,
And I think it's, you know, it's I want
you to kind of step back. And I did
because I feel I'm settled like most
people because it looks like the world I
grew up in, and I'm old,
is changing under me, right?
Because we were moving to this world you
know, I remember the Cold War ending and
Fukuyama saying, "This is, you know,
we're going to have this glorious age of
freedom and democracy." That was in the
1990s.
And you look back and say, "What
happened?"
And I found it very insulting when
people in New York would tell these
these people out there in the
hinterlands, "Learn to code."
I mean, how do you take a 55-year-old
man who works who's working in a factory
and
tell him go do something else like you
To begin with, you're already
discounting what the value of his life
has been. You're just I can replace you
with a worker in India. That's a very
insulting message.
So, I think you know, it's easy to look
at this and talk about Trump and
tariffs, but I think we've been building
up to this moment for a long time.
And Trump and tariffs are not going to
be the end of it. You're going to see
people in Europe getting elected who are
going to do their version of what they
said.
And I would say yes.
You know what? I look at I look at a
classroom like this and I worry because
there there are people in this room who
used to be doctors, engineers,
scientists. And for 40 years, finance
has been sucking up the best and the
brightest
out of other professions, bringing them
in here, turning them into traders and
bankers.
And that's not Yeah.
Yeah, but but there are a lot of people
who are science backgrounds and
engineers that we've sucked in. And I'm
not blaming them. They're making the
right choice for them because
engineering doesn't pay as much as being
a trader, and I can understand the
transition. But as a society, this is
not good to take your best and brightest
and put them in front of terminals in
places like New York City when they can
be Yeah.
There's there's
a kid who who went to MIT because he
developed this new way of speeding you
know, I I know all signs of that 17.
And I looked at where he was now, and
he's working at D.E. Shaw.
I said on their head spun around.
And I said, "That's an opportunity lost
for society that we took somebody who
could have made a difference as a doctor
or as a researcher."
But I think I would trace all of that
back to globalization as well because
it's shifting the power to financial
markets.
There are
there are so many things that that were
bubbling up to the surface.
It seems like we've
been leading up to this moment for a
long time.
And of course, a Dodge Mustang is a
disruption in that is company-wide that
somehow now is being tried out in
countries.
And I can understand the motive, which
is I mean, it's not the
But at the same time, you know, I know
people who are on Medicare and Social
Security, and they live check to check,
right? You break that system, and you
don't fix it quickly, people are dying,
right?
So, this is not disrupting Twitter and
laying off people. This is So,
you know, I can see events unfolding,
but I worry about whether we've thought
through the consequences because we're
just having to kind of jumping in as a
as a society.
You know, let it kind of roll around in
your mind because I don't have any
answers. I don't know how this will end.
I mean, we know how the French
Revolution ended, right? There is that
end game of people's heads being cut
off. We had the the Bolshevik
Revolution. So, there are times when
this ends violently.
And I hope that's not the end game. But
I think we need to do something. We need
to do something as
as a society, not just in America,
across the world,
to
take care of people because I hate when
people say
"This is a win."
Everything is a trade-off. Tell me who's
losing when you're winning.
So, when Uber is presenting, "Well, now
look at how great this is." Well, there
are losers. You got
cab drivers in New York City who now
don't have a job. There's a whole
ecosystem that's been disrupted. I
understand the net effect is positive,
but if we let the losers kind of slip
away and we don't take care of them,
there is this residue we're creating
that could be incredibly costly for us
in the long term.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
So, this is just
unlevered you got to weight by equity.
unlevered beta over the whole
unlevered beta
I just based it on that part.
The problem with taking weighted average
of
unlevered beta is you're assuming that
the leverage after the combination will
be the same for the acquisition company.
It was actually quite a big difference.
That's why I always go back to the
unlevered beta club.
And then you bring in the effect of
leverage sector.
Technically, I can take weighted average
of any number, right? So, if you wanted
an equity beta, I could take an equity
value market. So, if you have a
portfolio and he asks me what the beta
of your portfolio is, it's unlevered
beta times the equity in your portfolio.
I multiply by the equity invested in
each business, and I take away the debt.
But that's because you're controlling
leverage. Mhm. Thank you. You start with
unlevered beta ratio.
When you're doing the market, you have
to start with the unlevered beta first.
Yeah.
But if you want to find like, let's say
Because
What are you trying What are you trying
to do with weighted average? Tell me
what the what the what the context is
that you're talking about.
No, I just want Exactly. I just I just
wondering. I'm not doing the calculation
of anything, but I just wonder like
because you mentioned earlier that In
what context are you wondering? In what
context? As a company, as an investor?
As a company. As a company, you
definitely have to go down unlevered
beta.
Because debt is a choice.
Equity locks you into that choice. The
um Yeah, actually I mean like so, for
example, if I got a beta of if my firm
have five divisions
you should This is an
First is division. There's no such thing
as an This is I'm sorry.
No, it's No, but five divisions,
remember you always have to go down
unlevered beta because businesses don't
carry their own debt.
Thank you.
And then you can see it from the
outside.
And that is that is basically money that
the money coming in collected might end
up being distributed. So, even even
within the company, you have business
variance in your documentation.
I don't think you trace it out, right?
Yeah, yeah. So,
you can't trace So, basically, you got
to start with unlevered over the private
side.
Then you can allocate the debt of the
company and classify the businesses
based on who's got the most physical
But you always start with the unlevered
beta.
You eventually end up with another beta.
But you start with the unlevered beta
and you get to the levered beta.
Uh and first let me ask a question. So
in this example we used the cost of debt
of company to discount as a discount
rate to like find market value of the
debt, right? So I just wanted how is
that
like
why we do that? I thought we should use
the market rate as a discount rate. You
know what I mean?
The market rate is the rate at which you
can borrow money long term. Okay? That's
a cost of debt for the company. That's
our definition of cost of debt. No, but
for example, right? Uh
the company might my company, let's say
the rate on the rating is constant. But
What do you mean how is that constant?
Rates are changing, default spreads are
changing. How would it be constant?
Well, in order to get the cost of debt
of the company we use the risk-free cost
of default, right? At a point in time it
will be different tomorrow or the day
after.
I
Oh, all right.
But the default spread becomes The
rating agency risk-free rate and the
default spread of the rating agency
will be different tomorrow.
And the default spread will be different
as well. So why do you average it to a
number of 20 basis points? Yeah, they
just forgot about the risk rate as a
source of this
They forgot about the risk rate.
My bad.
Okay. And even the default spread will
change. You mean if the rating of
everything default spread is same?
So both the risk-free rate and default
spreads are moving numbers. Yeah. So
your cost of debt will be a moving
number and because it is a moving number
your market value of debt is reported.
Got it. And when we call debt we can
assume that is interest bearing debt.
Right. Any contractual commitment
Leases are contractual debt. You sign a
baseball player for 10 years and you
don't know how to count this debt.
Netflix agrees to carry a show for the
next 5 years and pay that's debt. Any
contractual commitments and interest
bearing debt.
Got it. But I just wonder because when I
search it up in the Capital IQ
their debt to equity ratio they just use
the book value.
So we cannot use the You cannot use
rate. Why would you want to use rate?
You can compute debt and equity and do
the ratio yourself. Why do you depend on
other people to give you the ratio? And
if they do the correct if they do
correctly then I don't need to You can't
assume that, right? So do the debt.
Whenever you have a ratio compute it
yourself. Got it. Well, one last
question. Can I
I just
So in order to get like
can I just go and look at it like at the
last 5 years of the interest expense
But why is that
Because the numbers will be different.
You are averaging over the last 5 years.
So
You always want to be right using
today's rate. Why do you average over
time and
This will make it more
There's no upside.
Thank you so much. Thank you, Professor.
We had a question about our case. Yeah,
so for in the write-up we were just kind
of
like the actual kind of writing of it
with the investment decision. Not much
relatively future. The write-up is
basically an eyeball assumption.
What is the debt beta?
Do a long beta.
What is the debt beta? Why would I do a
long beta?
What is the debt beta? You see what I'm
saying?
Hey.
I I I don't know what this is about.
Giving this assumption
Right? So
Do you do it for Then you got to make an
assumption about
So anything that you're adding to this
choice
This example
I said there's a pause and you come up
with the right answer.
Then you come up with There's so much
data of equity here.
About how people do it.
Anything that you did So don't repeat
the revenue part. Right.
in my case.
So that means like revenue the revenue
in there is going to be
I'll talk to you about it, man. There's
only three people here.
And if I understand that so doing what
we did
I think that
the decision Basically you like We were
saying not to take this project when
Or you may decide to take the project
in the style of the
If you session with me more difficult
But I think that the position
I'm asking him to tell me
Otherwise it seems
If you think it's a
But I'm assuming rate through the
application
Oh, I need
And are there qualitative factors at all
in play here or not?
You give qualitative factors and you
write it up like whatever
Got it.
And you're not looking for anything that
long. I think like no more than a couple
pages.
Do you want to see assumptions like in
the model we have? As long as you put it
does have built-in assumptions in the
model. Most of the assumptions are
coming from the book.
Yeah. Well, not like critical ones like
you have calculations that you might not
see with the cash flow. that are not
written down or something.
Most of the numbers You have to get the
book and black and back in. There's
something explicit that's going to be
held.
The moment everything
All right.
Thank you so much.
Hi. Hi. How are you? Good.
Yeah, so
I put a lot of months in finance.
I would say
Uh yes. Yes, he did. How did you have
it?
When you don't say anything she
mentioned it. I will uh inspect him on
the
I did it for actually the
It's an open seminar.
Okay, so let's go Okay, perfect. I come
to a seminar probably once every year or
two.
For the seminars or two day valuation
seminar. Okay. Is it entirely for the
university or is it just
I just wanted to meet you. I just wanted
to say hi. Look if I can get a quick
picture.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Professor.
Good luck to you.